ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IS IN
SESSION.
LIKE -- TO INVITE ALL THOSE WHO
HAVE BILLS BEFORE OUR COMMITTEE
TO COME ON DOWN.
GONNA TAKE THEM FOLLOW ORDER
ALTHOUGH -- NUMBER OF MEMBERS
HAVE SOME CONFLICTS SO EVEN IF
YOU'RE FURTHER DOWN THE LIST AND
YOU MIGHT THINK.
IT'S GONNA BE AWHILE MY COULD
COME ON IN AND WE CAN TAKE CARE
OF YOU QUICKLY.
WE ARE MEETING -- ON A DAY IN
WHICH THERE ARE SOME OTHER
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE SENATE.
AND WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE THAT
ARE DISSIPATING IN THOSE
HEARINGS SO.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A LIGHT --
COMMITTEE MEMBERSHIP BY. FOR A
WHILE.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
CANNOT DO OUR BUSINESS.
SO AUTHORS COME ON DOWN HERE.
HEARING MY VOICE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM LOCKER JOB.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
[inaudible]
LEVINE COOLEY [inaudible]
AND AREAS.
ASSEMBLY LEVINE YEAR HERE AT THE
RIGHT MOMENT.
BECAUSE THIS COMMITTEE IS
WAITING FOR YOU.
ALSO WE'RE GONNA BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE THIS -- TODAY AS WE DO
NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A QUORUM IS
ALWAYS MENTIONING WE HAVE A LOT
OF COMMITTEES GOING ON AT THE
SAME TIME.
BUT WE DO HAVE AN IMPORTANT
AUTHOR HERE.
IN THE ROOM ONLY WE INVITE YOU
AND WELCOME YOU TO OUR A
COMMITTEE OF THIS IS THE ITEM
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB.
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WE LOOK
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
YOU'RE VERY KIND THIS MORNING
AND I WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU
ABOUT AID AB.
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT IT'S REALLY A
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP BILL ON SOME
PRIOR LEGISLATION IT IMPOSES A
CAP ON CANOPY SIZES FOR CANNABIS
GROW SIT AS WELL CLEANS UP SOME
LANGUAGE ON APPELLATIONS OF
ORIGIN LANGUAGE.
IN SECTION TWO OF THE BILL THAT
CLARIFIES TERMINOLOGY IN THE BNP
CODE -- WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM
I'D BE GRATEFUL FOR AN AYE VOTE
GREAT THANK YOU SIR IS OR
ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF THIS -- GOOD
BILL.
THE ONE HERE TO TESTIFY AGAINST
THIS -- THIS BILL.
ALL RIGHTS OVER TO BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE A QUESTION
I THINK IT'S A GOOD CLEAN UP
BILL AND I APPRECIATE YOU BRING
IT FORWARD.
YOUR TIME HERE MUCH CENTER WILL
MOVE A MOTION WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY IS
HERE LIKE TO INVITE YOU OUT.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL.
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE THE WELCOME
YOU HERE AND WE LOOK FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
WELL A MISTER CHAIR OF PLEASURE
TO BE HERE ON BEHALF OF A BILL
OF TWENTY FIVE JOINT.
I MUST SAY.
THIS MORNING I'VE HAD YOUR
CONSOLE TO MISTER GAGE ON MY
MIND BECAUSE WE WORKED ON
EARTHQUAKES STUFF BACK AND IN
THE WAKE OF LOMA PRIETA.
SO I'M SURE THAT'S ON HIS MIND
TODAY -- HEY MISTER CHAIR A. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE REGARD TO
CERTIFICATION OF ANIMAL CONTROL
OFFICERS.
OF THE THEIR ACTIVITIES OR
FUNCTION OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PERFORMED TO ENSURE THE
PROTECTION OF THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF ANIMALS WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY.
AS WELL AS HUMANS LIVE AROUND
THEM [inaudible]
OUR IN RECENT YEARS OUR
BUSINESSES REPORTED THAT CAL
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION.
THE DEMONSTRATE THE BENEFIT OF
PROFESSIONALS ATION OF THIS
WORKFORCE [inaudible]
ON WHILE SOME ANIMAL CONTROL
OFFICERS POSSESSED PERSONALIZED
THE LEVEL TRAINERS HE VARIES
BASED UPON THE CITY OR COUNTY
FIND THEMSELVES IN. FOR THIS
BILL SIMPLY TRY TO ESTABLISH A
FRAMEWORK FOR PROFESSIONAL LIES
IN THIS AREA -- IT WILL PROMOTE
GREATER UNIFORMITY IN THIS
RESPECT I HAVE BEEN IS LAME.
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WILL OFFER
SUFFICIENT.
REGISTER BRISSAC ADDRESS GRITTY
BRIEFLY.
THANK YOU.
FLANK WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER.
ACURALINK OVER THE CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL WELFARE SUFFICIENT THERE
THAT CALIFORNIA LAW FIRST
DECISION IS THE MERGER OF THE
STATE HUMANE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS BEEN AROUND
FOR A HUNDRED AND TEN YEARS.
AN ANIMAL CONTROL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WHICH HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR ABOUT FIFTY THE MERGE
TWO YEARS AGO BECAUSE THERE'S SO
MUCH OVERLAP AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT SHE ACTED BEFORE
THEY MERGED WITH A CERTIFIED
HUMANE OFFICERS FOR THE STATE OF
FOR THE COURTS BECAUSE THEY ARE
SUPERVISED BY THE JUDICIAL.
COUNCIL WE ARE IN THE STATUTE
ALREADY THIS IS A VOLUNTARY OR A
CERTIFICATION THAT WOULD.
BE SOMETHING THAT ASH CAL
ANIMALS WOULD ADMINISTER SO WILL
NOT COST THE SEAT ANY MONEY BUT
WE ARE HOPING TO HELP
PROFESSIONALLY AS THE THE TRADE.
AND SINCE THEY OFTENTIMES
RESPOND ALONGSIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR ISSUES LIKE AN
ANIMAL FIGHTING RING OR HOARDING
OR CODE ENFORCEMENT MATTERS SO
WE THINK IT'S BEST FOR ALL OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT FAMILY IF
THEY'RE STANDARDIZED TRAINING.
IS RECOGNIZED AND MONITORED IN
SOME FASHION WITHOUT COSTING THE
STATE ANY MONEY SO WE HAVE CREE
I'VE IT TAKES A VERY GOOD ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT
SENATOR ACTUALLY.
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
APPEARING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING -- BECAUSE
IT'S SO IMPORTANT AT ALL OF US
WHO LOVE ANIMALS I I MYSELF THE
FAMILY I HAVE FIVE KIDS.
THE DOGS HAVE BEEN WITH US FOR
EVER AND AND I I REALLY APPLAUD
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
BECAUSE IT WILL PROFESSIONALS
EVEN MORE SO.
THOSE THAT WORK WITH ANIMALS
EVERY DAY AND ESPECIALLY THEIR
APPREHENSION TREATMENT AND SO ON
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
UNIFORMS TRADING.
SO LET ME ASK YOU THIS -- TO
REACH THAT CERTIFICATION LEVEL
WHICH WOULD NOT BE GIVEN TO JUST
ANYONE.
DO THEY NEED TO COME UP HERE
WHERE CAN THEY RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND HOW ARE
WE GOING TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
HELLO MISS LANG AT REST AT ALL
OFFER COMMENT THERE ARE.
A FEW HUMANE -- ACADEMY THERE'S
ONE IN MARIN THERE'S ONE IN SAN
DIEGO AND THEY ALSO ARE ABLE TO
ARRANGE THROUGH POST FOR
TRAININGS I USING BATONS THEIR
AUTHORIZED THE LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR.
TO UTILIZE BATONS IF THEY HAD
THE PROPER TRAINING SAID.
THAT THE ASSOCIATION ALREADY HAS
SOME TRAININGS AROUND THE STATE
TO WOULDN'T BE REQUIRED TO
TRAVEL TO SACRAMENTO AND AND
THEY WOULD RECOGNIZE AS EXISTING
ACADEMIES.
AND ALSO TRY TO OFFER MORE
TRAINING NIELSEN ANNUAL
CONFERENCE FOR THERE'S LOTS OF
TRAINING PROVIDED.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU ARE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR GOOD WORK IN THIS
AREA AND THE ANALYSIS A NUMBER
OF FIVE OF ISSUES ARE RAISED
THAT.
THAT WE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER AS
YOU MOVE THE BILL FORWARD AND
GET A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THOSE
YOU'RE WELCOME TO ADDRESS THEM
IN YOUR CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
I CONFESS I HAVE NOT
[inaudible]
THE ON PAGE [inaudible]
SEVEN MY PREVIOUS.
I THINK A ON THE ISSUE OF A
SUNSET PART OF THIS PURPOSE IS
TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT
THIS.
PURSUING THIS SORT OF TRAINING.
WILL SUPPORT THEM IN THEIR
CAREER AND BE RECOGNIZED AND
VALUED BY THEIR LOCAL CITIES.
SO I THINK YOU SUNSET SORT OF
UNDERMINES INCENTIVE OF
INDIVIDUALS TO TRAIN I'M
[inaudible]
I SO I I GUESS I HESITATE TO SAY.
I AM ABSOLUTELY DOWN ON A SUNSET.
BUT  A FEEL IN THIS SORT OF
VERY YOU'RE TRYING TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO CARVE OUT TIME AND
THEIR CALENDAR. TO GO TO THESE
TRAINS TO PURSUE THE TRAINS.
I WOULD WANT TO THINK THROUGH
HOW SUNSET INTERACTS WITH THAT
SORT OF MOTIVATION THAT A
RECOMMENDATION YEAH I THINK THAT
WE JUST ASK THAT YOU TAKE A TAKE
A LOOK AT IT AND COMMON FEW
OTHERS.
REGARDING THE COMPOSITION OF THE
BOARD -- YEAH I WOULD DISCUSS
WITH THEM HOW THAT.
MIGHT BE DONE -- I THINK THE
STRENGTH OF CERTIFICATION
DESERVE BE BROAD BASED AND
REFLECT EXPERTISE FROM A VARIETY
OF SECTORS [inaudible]
SEOUL ON I WILL LAST I WILL WORK
OF MY SPONSORS IN YOUR STAFF TO
THINK ABOUT IS THERE A FOR THE
CROSS SECTION THAT WE MIGHT
SPECIFIED -- AND WE GO ON TO DAY
IN HOUSES BECAUSE ANA IDENTIFY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AND HOW
THAT'S TAKING INTO ACCOUNT ALL
THINGS JUST.
TO YES YEAH TAKE A LOOK AT THE
HIS HIS UNIFORM YEAH I WILL I
WILL INDEED IN ON THIS ISSUE IS
SPECIFICALLY THE BOARD
COMPOSITION THINK THAT'S A A
GOOD ISSUE WE WANTED TO BE
REPRESENTATIVE OF BROAD SKILL
SET.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I WILL
LOOK AT THOSE PERFECT PLACE FOR
GREAT THANK YOU AND WE'LL HAVE A
MOTION WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM SIR
THAN YOU VERY MUCH.
WHO IS THE?
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE OF I THINK IS
HERE WELCOME ME AND THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER. TWO ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FORTY ONE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE.
AS A NUMBER OF OTHER SENATE
COMMITTEES MEETING AT THIS TIME
SO WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WILL BEGIN.
HEARING YOUR BILL AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE WELCOME YOU [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWO FOUR ONE AB TWO FOUR ONE
WILL REDUCE DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH CARE BY MANDATING THAT
CONTINUED EDUCATION COURSES
REQUIRED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT BOARD AND
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING.
INCLUDE CURRICULUM ON IMPLICIT
BIAS CURRICULUM SHALL INCLUDE
EXAMPLES OF HOW IMPLICIT BIAS
AFFECTS PERCEPTIONS AND
TREATMENT AND OR STRATEGIES TO
REDUCE UNINTENDED BUYS SEES IN
DECISION MAKING.
THAT MAY CONTRIBUTE TO HEALTH
CARE DISPARITIES.
MY OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS.
I HAVE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
MADE SURE THAT THE BILL APPLIES
ONLY TO COURSES THAT HAVE A
DIRECT PATIENT CARE COMPONENT.
INPATIENT CARE IMPLICIT BIAS
PARTICULARLY CAN THREATEN THE
LIVES OF PATIENTS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS CONSTANTLY ARE
MAKING RAPID DECISIONS UNDER
STRESSFUL CONDITIONS THAT MAY
ALTER THE LIVES OF PATIENTS.
IF WE SUB CONSCIOUSLY BELIEVE
THAT CERTAIN LIVES ARE LESS
VALUABLE THAN OTHERS THEN WE MAY
BE LESS LIKELY TO TRY TO SAVE
THOSE LIVES. FOR EXAMPLE STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THE FOLLOWING.
BLACK WOMEN ARE THREE TO FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
PREGNANCY OR CHILDBIRTH RELATED
CAUSES THAN WHITE WOMEN.
WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY TO SURVIVE
A HEART ATTACK WHEN TREATED BY A
FEMALE PHYSICIAN. 18% OF PEOPLE
WHO IDENTIFY AS LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL TRANS OR CLEAR AVOID
DOCTORS OFFICES FOR FEAR OF
DISCRIMINATION AND PROVIDER BIAS.
AND LATINO MEN IN CALIFORNIA OR
21% LESS LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE
BEST TREATMENT FOR HIGH RISK
PROSTATE CANCER THAN WHITE MEN.
WITH THE DISTRICTS PARTICULARLY
DIRE THERE IS AN URGENCY AND
FINDING A SOLUTION.
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE AT THE FOREFRONT TO
IMPROVE TREATMENT AND OUTCOMES
FOR PATIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN UNDER
SERVED BY THEIR HEALTH PROVIDERS.
PASSED LEGISLATION INTEGRATING
CULTURAL COMPETENCY CURRICULUM
INTO CONTINUED MEDICAL EDUCATION
FOR MEDICAL BOARD LICENSEES
SHOWS US THAT IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS BILL IS NOT ONLY POSSIBLE
BUT IT'S BENEFICIAL. TO
LICENSEES.
AB TWO FOUR ONE TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE PREVENTATIVE
APPROACH TO REDUCE DISPARITIES
IN HEALTH CARE.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS
DOCTOR ACKERMAN ASSOCIATE
CLINICAL PROFESSIONAL AND DOCTOR
RICHARD HOOD PAST PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIONAL MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
VERY GOOD THE FIRST WITNESS.
OKAY YOU COULD PRESS THE BUTTON
AND THERE YOU GO IT'S WORKING IS
THAT WORKING OKAY WELCOME.
OF PLEASE NOTE THAT MY COMMENTS
ARE MINE AND DO NOT NECESSARILY
REFLECT THE VIEWS OF UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
EQUITABLE CARE IS IN DIRECT
ALIGNMENT WITH THE PHILOSOPHY
AND VALUES OF THE NURSING
PROFESSION.
APPEARS COMMITMENT TO SERVE
OTHERS AS WHAT WE WOULD HAS MADE
NURSING ONE OF THE MOST TRUSTED
PROFESSIONS.
AS A NURSE I AM HERE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT AND HEALTH CARE
WE ARE NOT LIVING UP TO HER
PERFECT OUR POTENTIAL TO
PROVIDING QUALITY HEALTHCARE FOR
ALL.
HELP THEIR HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES ARE VERY WELL
DOCUMENTED AND THE HEALTH CARE
LITERATURE.
THEIR PERNICIOUS AN ON GOING.
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS AND HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS CAN LEAD TO HEALTH
DISPARITIES SUCH AS IN ADEQUATE
TREATMENT OF CONDITIONS LIKE
PAIN.
OBESITY CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
ASTHMA AND MENTAL HEALTH.
NOT ONLY DOES UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
CONTRIBUTE TO UNDER TREATMENT
BUT STDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
PROVIDERS WITH MORE IMPLICIT
BIASES ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
NEGATIVE INTERACTIONS WITH
PATIENTS.
THIS IMPACTS THE TRUST PATIENT
TOP AND HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
AND THE LIKELIHOOD.
THAT PATIENTS WILL SEEK HEALTH
CARE.
THE PARADOX WITH UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS IS THAT THE THINGS THAT
DWELL IN OUR CONSCIOUSNESS.
ARE NOT NECESSARILY IN ALIGNMENT
WITH OUR PERSONAL OR
PROFESSIONAL VALUES THIS MEANS
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A GROUP OF
BAD PROVIDERS THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR HEALTH
DISPARITIES.
RATHER IT IS LIKELY THAT IT'S A
COLLECTIVE ISSUE THAT INCLUDES
CARING WELL INTENTIONED
PROVIDERS WHO AT TIMES.
ARE MAKING HEALTHCARE DECISIONS
BASED ON BY US RATHER THAN
STANDARDIZE CARE.
THIS IS MOST LIKELY TO HAPPEN
WHEN PROVIDERS ARE TIRED ON
CERTAIN OVER BURDENED OR HAD
MULTIPLE DEMANDS ON THEIR
ATTENTION.
I'M CONSCIOUS BUYERS CAN BE
MITIGATED WE PROPOSE THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY ONE AND
IS THE FIRST STEP IN ASSURING
HEALTH.
CARE EQUITY FOR ALL.
HE VERY MUCH YOUR NECK NEXT WHEN
THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
RODNEY HOOD I'M THE PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND I ALSO
SERVED ON THE EDITORIAL BOARD OF
THE JOURNAL CALLED RACIAL AND
ETHNIC HEALTH DISPARITIES.
THESE UP FOCUS ON ELIMINATING
HELP EQUITIES IN OUR COUNTRY.
OF FOR DECADES PUBLISHED
LITERATURE HAS DOCUMENT RACIAL
AND ETHNIC HEALTH DISPARITIES
THAT CONSISTENTLY REVEAL
MINORITY AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES SUFFER THE WORST
HEALTH OUTCOMES IN EVEN LESS
LIFE EXPECTANCY THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION. TWENTY YEARS AGO.
THE NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF
MEDICINE PUBLISHED ONE OF THE
FIRST ARTICLES ON HEALTH
INEQUITY.
POINTING OUT THAT BLACK PATIENTS
ESPECIALLY BLACK WOMEN
[inaudible]
WENT.
WHEN TREAT IT MOSTLY BY WHITE
PHYSICIANS RECEIVE LESS THAN
THERAPEUTIC CARE?
NOW AT THAT TIME THE AUTHORS OF
THE ARTICLE WERE PUZZLED AS TO
WHY THIS OCCURRED.
BECAUSE THE PATIENTS WERE ARE
ACTUALLY PAID ACTORS AND
EVERYBODY HAD THE SAME THING
EXCEPT FOR RACE.
AND GENDER.
HOWEVER WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF
THE HEART THE IMPLICIT BIAS
TESTS STUDIES BEGIN TO MEASURE
THESE PARAMETERS WITHIN OF
PHYSICIANS.
IN A TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
ANOTHER STUDY WAS PUBLISHED.
LOOKING AT OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED OF PHYSICIANS AND
BASICALLY WHAT IT SHOWED WAS
THAT THESE PHYSICIANS HAD A HIGH
ANTI BLACK IMPLICIT BIAS.
IN WHEN THEY LOOKED AT THE THIS
RESULT IN HE DECISION MAKING IT
SHOW THAT THESE PHYSICIANS MADE
MORE NEGATIVE DECISIONS FOR THE
OF OUR BLACK PATIENTS RATHER
THAN WHITES [inaudible]
SO.
THIS RAISES THE QUESTION.
WILL PROVIDE IS BIASES
INFLUENCED ERASURE DECISIONS.
I BELIEVE IT IS CLEAR THAT
PROVIDE A BIASES IMPLICIT OR
OTHERWISE CONTRIBUTE TO MANY OF
THE HEALTH INEQUITIES SOME OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED
ALREADY.
AS A FIRST STEP TO RESOLVE THESE
DISPARITIES INEFFECTIVE
DIVERSITY A CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TRAINING MUST INCLUDE IMPLICIT
BIAS EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
I CURRENTLY SERVE AS CHAIR OF
THE SAN DIEGO GANG COMMISSION
FOR PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION.
AND WORK CLOSELY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING HAS BEEN
COOPERATING INTO THEIR TRAINING
IN SAN DIEGO.
BUT THE QUESTION IS DOES THIS
WORK.
NATIONAL DATA SHOWS IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
BUT THE POSITIVE RESULTS CAN BE
SHORTLY OF IT MUST BE SUSTAINED
AND REINFORCE WITH REPETITIVE
TRAINING.
THIS SEEMS TO MAKE SENSE BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THE LIFE LONG LEARN
SOCIALIZE STEREO TYPING TRIGGERS.
THAT LEAD TO BIASES ARE
REPEATEDLY IMPRINTED INTO A SUB
CONSCIENCE.
THROUGHOUT OUR LIFE IN CAN ONLY
BE REMEDIED.
WITH REPEATED ATTEMPTS AT RE
SOCIALIZING UP FRONT.
SO I BELIEVE A. B. TWO FORTY ONE
WILL SERVE AS A NECESSARY FIRST
STEP TO ADDRESSING CRUCIAL
NEEDED.
EDUCATION TRAINING OF OUR
CURRENT FUTURE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS IN IN THE MOST DIVERSE
STATE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
IF YOU COULD JUST IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND YOUR SUPPORT
POSITION THAT WOULD BE TERRIFIC.
MR TURN MEMBERS BUT THE ARMS ARE
ON BEHALF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ANTIMATTER HERE BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RAY JENNIFER SOMOS WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORTH.
WE CAN MAKE A LITTLE ROOM AT THE
TABLE HERE.
FOR ARE YOU UNDER FOR THE
MICROPHONE YEAH OKAY THAT'S FINE
THAT'S FINE GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME STILL THE HARASSER
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING AND THE
CHIEF FOR LEGISLATION.
THE BOARD IS MADE A DECISION TO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED HOWEVER I
DO WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT THE
BORDER WHICH THE NURSING DOES
SUPPORT IMPLICIT BIAS FOR ALL OF
OUR LICENSEES WHICH A FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER THE ISSUE THAT THE BOARD
HAS RECENTLY.
FOUNDED IS UNRESOLVED IS THE
INTENT ON HOW IT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED WE AVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND WE
ARE PLEASED THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO WORK WITH US.
AND SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT OUR
NEXT BOARD MEETING WE WILL BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
TERRIFIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING AND SHARING YOUR
TESTIMONY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I SEE NOW WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
CENTER PAN AND CENTER OUR
CHILDREN.
I THANK YOU AND WHAT THANK YOU
SOME NUMBER UNLIKE ADULT FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD -- I
MEAN THERE'S BEEN NUMEROUS
STUDIES LOOKING AT THE ISSUE OF
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND ACTUALLY
DISPARITIES AND THE HEALTH CARE
AND WELL -- AND CERTAINLY
IMPLICIT.
BIAS IS PART OF THIS AND SO -- I
KNOW THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IN
THE MEDICAL EDUCATION WORLD
WHERE I CAME FROM -- THERE
CERTAINLY -- NOW THE GREATER
AWARENESS BUT CERTAINLY MORE
EDUCATION -- THERE AND OF COURSE
WITH CMV WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT
WE EDUCATE OUR CURRENT
PRACTITIONERS IT'S NOT JUST
SOMETHING FOR THE STUDENTS AND
RESIDENTS ARE COMING THROUGH BUT
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTIVELY IN
PRACTICE.
AND AND ALSO RECOGNIZE YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS JUST
MORE JUST MEDICINE AS WELL I
MEAN IT'S WE NEED TO LOOK ACROSS
THE HEALTH PROFESSION SO.
ASSEMBLY AND THE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND WITH LIKE
TO MOVE THE BUILT APPROPRIATE
TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR PANTS AND
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU SIMPLY ONE FROM BEING
IN THIS THROUGH ASSEMBLY WOMAN --
I I AM SO PLEADED HONORED THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS I THINK THAT
AS SO MANY MINORITIES WHO ARE
NOW -- IN MEDICINE -- IN A
PROFESSIONS AND SOMEONE IN IS
ALMOST SHAMEFUL THAT WE HAVE TO
PUT A BILL ON THE TABLE. TO GET
PEOPLE TO REALIZE TAT EQUALITY
AND FAIRNESS AND EQUAL TREATMENT
ACROSS THE BOARD IS PART OF YOUR
OVERALL PARTY YOUR
PROFESSIONALISM.
AND I THINK THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP TO OPEN THAT DOOR TO EVEN
MORE EQUALITY IN MEDICINE MORE
EQUALITY WHEN PEOPLE ARE JUDGING
ONE ANOTHER.
AND LOOKING INTO THEIR EYES AND
SAID YOU ARE WHAT I AM AND IN AS
WE INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE --
OF MINORITIES IN PROFESSIONS
THEN IT'LL START LOOKING LIKE
AMERICA IT'LL START LOOKING --
LIKE EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA SO I
THINK THIS IS GREAT I I AM
TOTALLY -- I I JUST CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT WE HAD TO DO THIS
BUT I SUPPORTED A 100% AND I
THANK YOU FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
YOU DO CERTAINLY HAVE MY BOAT
VERY GOOD -- I TAKE A PAUSE FOR
JUST A MOMENT ESTABLISH QUORUM
SO THE SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE
ROLL.
GLAZER HERE LATER HERE CHIANG
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HERE DODD
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI HERE HELLO LEYVA.
THEY'VE BEEN HERE PAN.
PAN HERE WILK.
GOOD SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM A
SEVEN WOMAN I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING IT FORWARD AND
CERTAINLY THE FAX.
THAT YOU PRESENTED ARE STARTLING
AND AND AND VERY TROUBLESOME AND
I KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET OUT WITH THIS IMPORTANT.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THE
ANALYSIS RAISES A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS I WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THEM HERE
TERMS OF WHO'S INCLUDED IN ARE
NOT AND AND THE ABILITY DID HAVE.
TO CORRECT OVERSIGHT SO WE CAN
MAKE SURE IT WORKS YES SO --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND MISTER CHAIR IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT I KNOW IN THE
BE -- AMENDMENTS AND SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS A QUESTION WAS ASKED
ABOUT -- INDIOS ARE INCLUDED AND
IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY ARE INCLUDED SINCE THEY ARE
ALSO PART OF THE CODE THAT WAS
REFERENCED BE PC SECTION.
TWO FOUR FIVE THREE EIGHT SO --
WE CAN CERTAINLY WORK TO KIND OF
CLARIFY THAT BUT IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY WOULD BE
PART OF THAT -- THERE WERE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS RELATED --
TO JUST THE AUDITING -- AND THAT
IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE
DECIDED TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
GIVE -- THE BEER AND TIME TO TO
GET UP IN -- IN MOVING IS ALSO
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY DO
AUDITS EVERY FIVE YEARS AND
THEIR AUDITING ONE FIFTH OF THE
PROVIDER POPULATION SO WITH
ROLLING -- AND THIS BILL WOULD
ACTUALLY REQUIRE THE BOARD TO
COME UP WITH REGULATIONS FIRST
AND THEN AFTER THAT THE NEXT
STEP IS WORKING TO INTEGRATE
WITH THE PROVIDER SO WE'RE
HOPING THAT THERE'S ENOUGH.
SPACE IN BETWEEN THE TIME THAT
THIS IS SIGNED IN ONE
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD HAPPEN TO
ALLOW FOR A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO HOW IT
WOULD BE DONE.
VERY GOOD -- THANK YOU AND I
GUESS -- I'D COURAGE TO WORK
WITH OUR STAFF ON THE ON THE
WHO'S INCLUDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT FOR CLARIFYING THE MEASURE.
THAT SECTION REALLY COVERS ALL
THAT YOU WANT TO COVER SO WE
WANT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT APPLIES TO
EVERYBODY.
APPLICABLE FORGET THAT -- WHEN I
RECOGNIZE A MOTION A MOMENT BUT
IT'S LIKE TO CLOSE ANYTHING AND
AND FINAL COMMENTS GOING TO MAKE
YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
I CERTAINLY DO NOT COME SEE THIS
BILL AS A SILVER BULLET I DON'T
KNOW THAT?
YOU NEED BILL REALLY IS BUT I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND RECOGNITION OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACED -- MY
FOLKS IN THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
AND THEIR PATIENTS AND TO JUST
REITERATE THAT AB TWO FOR ONE IS
ABOUT PROVIDING STRATEGIES FOR
UNDERSTANDING AND REDUCING THE
IMPACT OF BIAS.
IN ORDER TO REDUCE DISPARATE
OUTCOMES AND ENSURE EQUITY -- IN
TREATMENT IN PRACTICE AND IN
CARE SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
ARE YET I RECOGNIZE MOTIONS
SENATOR PAN.
WITH THAT -- SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE DODD
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA HAND
FIVE HAND I WILL.
AS FOR VOTES WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLL UP AND PERHAPS MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE VERY
MUCH.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN BY SELLING
MEMBER GABRIEL WHO IS HERE.
SIR COME ON UP WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE.
IS THAT TASK FORCE AN ADVERSE
DRUG EVENTS PRESCRIPTIONS.
THAT WE WELCOME YOU AND YOU CAN
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY 2%
EIGHTY THREE EIGHT SEVEN WHICH
WILL CREATE A TASK FORCE TO
PROVE.
PRESCRIPTION DRUG LABELING AND
REDUCE ADVERSE DRUG EVENTS.
ADVERSE DRUG EVENTS ARE SERIOUS
CHALLENGE THE ACCOUNT FOR NEARLY
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS AND COST THE U. S.
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM FIT FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS EVERY YEAR. ONE
OF THE LEADING CAUSES OF SUCH
EVENTS IS CONFUSING PRESCRIPTION
DRUG LABELING.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT UP 225%
OF MEDICATION ERRORS CAN BE
ATTRIBUTED TO NAME CONFUSION AND
33% OF PACKAGING AND LABELING
CONFUSION. FOR SOME PATIENTS
ESPECIALLY SENIORS THERE CAN BE
SEVERE AND POTENTIALLY FATAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR FAILING O
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN TWO
MEDICATIONS THAT LOOK OR SOUND
ALIKE.
OUR PRIVATION OF THIS BILL WHICH
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SUCH ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BY ENCOURAGING
PHYSICIANS.
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH THEIR
PATIENTS ABOUT INCLUDING THE
PURPOSE OF A MEDICATION ON ITS
LABEL WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT INCLUDING SUCH INFORMATION
WOULD BE AN EASY AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAY. TO AVOID
CONFUSION REDUCE ERRORS AND
IMPROVE PATIENT SAFETY.
HOWEVER AFTER CONVERSATIONS WITH
NUMEROUS STAKEHOLDERS IT HAS
BECOME CLEAR THAT PATIENTS AND
CAREGIVERS WOULD BENEFIT FROM A
MORE ROBUST PROCESS.
THAT WILL ALLOW EXPERTS TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO DEVELOP A
BROADER POLICY ON THIS ISSUE.
EIGHTY THREE EIGHT SEVEN WILL
BRING TOGETHER DIVERSE GROUP OF
EXPERTS TO DEVELOP BEST
PRACTICES TO PROVE PRESCRIPTION
DRUG LABELING AND REDUCE ADVERSE
DRUG EVENTS.
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ASSISTANCE
IN DRAFTING THE AMENDMENTS TO
CREATE A TASK FORCE IN A PROCESS
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THE TASK FORCE WILL PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WILL
IMPROVE LABELING IN A MATTER
THAT PROTECTS PATIENT SAFETY
SAVE LIVES AND REDUCE HEALTHCARE
COSTS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS MAKING OUT READ A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE OUT.
WE GET YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MEGAN ALL
RIGHT AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE DAYS.
EIGHT SEVEN WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US OVER
THE PAST FEW MONTHS AS WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH KIND OF ALL THE INS
AND OUTS OF LABELING AND AND
ENDED UP SETTLED ON THIS TASK
FORCE THAT WE THINK WILL BE
REALLY EFFECTIVE.
IN AND IDENTIFYING WAYS TO
REDUCE ADVERSE DRUG EVENTS AND
MEDICATION ADHERENCE.
I WOULD THINK THAT THIS IS A
GREAT ROUTE TO GO WERE EXCITED
TO BE ABLE TO HOPEFULLY BE
INVOLVED IN THIS STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO DEVELOP THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND WORK WITH THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY IN THE BACK CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD IN DEVELOPING
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND SO
WITH THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT PLEASE CONTACT.
CARE MATT ROBERTS -- CAP I AM
VERY I DEFINITELY THINK THE
OFFER ARM THE CHAIR -- FOR AND
THE THE STAFF FOR THAT ANALYSIS
WERE PLEASE BE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WITH THAT -- THE MEMBERS
WANT TO LIE SECOND THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME SHEILA SILVA
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
RETIREES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THIRTY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MR MEMBERS TO MADDEN RIPPED IN
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE MIRACLES OF
CARDIOLOGY.
AND CONFERENCES ID PLASTIC
SURGEONS WE PREVIOUSLY HAD AN
OPPOSE UNLESS A MINUTE.
OF POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WITH
THE AMENDMENTS WE REMOVE
OPPOSITION TO USE WHILE ALSO
THINK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
PARTICULARLY FOR THE TIME TO
LISTEN TO OUR CONCERNS.
ON THAT BUT WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AT THIS
POINT THANK YOU GOOD THANK YOU.
RENTS SPENCER MAP THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
LIKE ECHO THE COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUE TO MADDEN AND THANK
THE AUTHOR THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
WORK THEY'RE MOVING OPPOSITION
GOING TO NEUTRAL THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WINNERS SUPPORT OKAY
BRING OUR BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
I BEFORE -- WE WE TAKE A MOTION
ON THE BILL THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED IN
THE ANALYSIS.
SOME REMEMBER COULD YOU ADDRESS
THEM IN REGARD TO THE INCLUSION
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS.
AND THE LIMITATION ON
REPRESENTATION.
SOME PAGE SHOT TEN OF ELEVEN
YEAH YEAH YEAH I'M SO WE
APPRECIATE THE THE THOUGHTFUL
FEEDBACK FROM THE COMMITTEE I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
THAT DEFINITELY WANT TO CONSIDER --
TIGHTENING UP SOME OF THOSE
DEFINITIONS SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S SUPPORT SOMEONE
IS BOARD CERTIFIED -- AND AND
ALSO WILLING TO TO CONSIDER --
YEAH -- AMENDING TO INCLUDE --
ADDITIONAL FOLKS ARE HAPPY TO
CONSIDER THOSE AND AND TO MAKE
THOSE MOMENTS GOOD WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN THIS
AREA THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
WE ALL HAVE SNSITIVITY TO WORRY
ABOUT.
AND NOT AN EASY THING TO GET OUT
AND I THINK YOUR YOUR APPROACH
TO THE STATUS THIS TASK FORCE
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND I THINK
IT'S GOING TO ADVANCE THE
IMPORTANT GOALS THAT WE ALL HAVE.
YOUR LEADING THIS EFFORT WITH
THAT ANYTHING ONE SAYING CLOSING
YEAH I JUST THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR RIGHT FOR
YOUR VERY HELPFUL THOUGHTFUL
FEEDBACK ON THIS BILL AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
ON THAT I THINK I SAW CENTER.
PAN MAKE THE MOTION FOR THE BILL.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
HI GLAZER I'D CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA PAN HI
CAN I WILL CALL RIGHT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THAT HAS AN EFFORT TO
GET OUT WILL HOD THE ROLE OF
THE TRAPS IN MEMPHIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
WORK PERCENT.
SO I WE WE HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OF ONE AND THEN I THINK
WHAT I SENATOR WILL KEEP GOING
TO PRESENT FOR CENTER HUESO IS
THAT CORRECT.
SO -- ABSENT AN AUTHOR AND ONE
OF ENCOURAGE ANY ASSEMBLY
AUTHORS WHO HAVE BILLS UP TO
PLEASE COME TO COME COME FORWARD
HERE.
SO WE CAN HEAR THEM BUT IF FIVE
CAN I GET A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THIS IS AB
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN PATTERSON.
EMOTIONS BEEN MADE IT SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD THERE WILL BE
OTHER YANNI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA PAN.
PAN AYE WILK HI WILL GOT VERY
GOOD WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT --
VOTE ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE THIS IS S. R. FORTY
EIGHT BY CENTER HUESO AND HE'S.
SUBMITTED VERY AUTHORIZED -- THE
OFFICIAL LETTER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS
THINKING AT THE TIME BUT
DIRECTING THAT SENATOR WILL
COULD PRESENT THIS ON HIS BEHALF
SO WITH THAT -- FORMAL
AUTHORIZATION WE WELCOME CENTER
WILL TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU I MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
MY PRESIDING S. S. R. FORTY
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR HUESO
WHO IS CHAIRING THE SENATE
SENATE ENERGY -- COMMITTEE -- AS
WE CURRENTLY SPEAK THAT'S OUR
FORTY EIGHT URGES LEADERS OF OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO OPPOSE AND
AVOID ANY TERRORIST LEVELED ON
MEXICAN GOODS.
EARLIER THIS YEAR A PLAN WAS
ANNOUNCED TO IMPOSE A FIVE BIRDS
5% TARIFF ON MEXICAN GOODS
GRADUALLY INCREASING 225% WHICH
WAS SET TO TAKE EFFECT ON JUNE
TENTH. TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
TEARS WERE CONTINUE ON THE FLOW
OF MIGRANTS INTO THE UNITED
STATES AND ALTHOUGH SUCH
TERRORISTS HAVE SINCE BEEN
INDEFINITELY SUSPENDED THE
AMBIGUITY REGARDING THEIR
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE A CAUSE
FOR CONCERN FOR THE ECONOMIC
WELL BEING.
OF CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND
BUSINESSES FREE TRADE BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA MEXICO HAS PLAYED AN
INTEGRAL ROLE IN BUILDING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY ECONOMY TO
BECOMING THE FIFTH LARGEST IN
THE WORLD.
TERRACE BASED ON MEXICO WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL TO BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA JOB MARKET AND THE
ECONOMY.
IF TEARS WERE OF IMPOSED
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA WOULD BE LOST
IN NEARLY SIX HUNDRED NINETY
NINE MILLION WORTH OF EXPORTS TO
MEXICO WOULD BE TARGETED DUE TO
TRADE RETALIATION.
WE MUST PRESERVE CALIFORNIA'S
LONG STANDING FREE TRADE
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR CROSS
BORDER NEIGHBOR AND AVOID TRADE
ARMS ARM WARS THAT MIGHT HELP
PROGRESS ON THE UNITED STATES
MEXICO CANADA AGREEMENT.
ON BEHALF OF CENTER WAYS THOUGH
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE YET THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THAT WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS CENTER ARCHULETA.
A CENTER ARCHES WHAT IS ABOUT TO
MOVE THIS BILL ANYTHING WINCING
CLOSING ESPECIALLY ASPIRIN I'VE
OKAY CENTER ACTUAL AS MOVE THE
BILL SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MEASURES TO BE ADOPTED AND SENT
TO THE SENATE FLOOR GLAZER HI
GLAZER AYE CHIANG ARCHULETA.
VIRTUAL IT AYE DODD GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA FAN ALL
RIGHT CAN I WILK HI OKAY THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
APPLE HOLD THE ROLE OF
CONTRAPTION MEMBERS THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK.
I SEE I ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO IS
HERE.
WELCOME AND THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB SIXTEEN
NINETY SIX SIR WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I'M SENATORS.
AB SIXTY NINETY SIX ESTABLISHES
THE PROCESS INCLUDING TIMELINES.
FOR SUBMITTING PROPOSALS TO GOAL
BIZ ON THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT TO OPERATE%
AND INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
FOREIGN INVESTMENT OFFICE.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY PROVIDE
SCHOOL BIZ WITH THE WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH FOREIGN
OFFICES
AND SPECIFIES WHICH ACTION OGLE
BIZ IS TO TAKE ALL ONCE IT'S
THIRTY TERMINATION IS TO MOVE
FORWARD HAS BEEN MADE.
EXISTING LAW IS HOWEVER SILENT
AS TO HOW ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ENTITIES CAN PROPOSED THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF JOINTLY AND
MINISTER OF FOREIGN TRADE
OFFICES.
WHILE GULBIS HAS NOTED THAT
THERE ARE THEY ARE VERY FLEXIBLE
IN HOW PROPOSALS CAN BE BROUGHT
FORWARD STAKEHOLDER GROUPS HAVE.
YET TESTIFIED THAT CONFUSION
REMAINS AND THAT MORE STRUCTURE
WOULD BE MORE HELPFUL I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR I FELT VERY VERY GOOD ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
GREAT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THAT RING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
ANYONE IS SAYING CLOSING HIS WE
A CRANK UP YOUR BILL I ASKED WE
I WILL THINK YOU'RE MIGHT FORGET
CENTER PANDAS MOVE THE BILL THAT
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
HI GLAZER I'D CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA PAN HI
CAN I WILL.
THAT -- WE'RE FOR THAT MATTER ON
CALL FOR ABSENT SENATORS FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PRESENT A
GOOD BILL THANK YOU SENATORS
OKAY.
WE'RE WAITING FOR AUTHORS NOW WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO AND
LOWER THE TWO REMAINING AUTHORS
IF YOU CAN HEAR MY VOICE.
I HOPE THAT YOU'LL MAKE YOUR WAY
DOWN TO OUR COMMITTEE WERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE CASE
YOU'RE WONDERING.
WE CAN TAKE IT YES SO WE WILL
WILL TAKE MOTIONS ON THOSE BILLS
OF FOR WAITING FOR THE AUTHOR SO.
WE DID HERE EARLIER -- ITEM.
FOR AB FIVE EIGHT FIVE EIGHT BY
LEVINE IS THERE A MEMBER WOULD
LIKE HIM MOVE THAT BILL.
THIS IS A THIS IS A CLEAN UP
CANNABIS CULTIVATION BUILDS A
GOOD BILL AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
ARTS CENTER ACTUAL LETTERS MOVED
ITEM FOR AB FIVE EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARE TO LET AYE DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA PAN.
AND I WILK.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT
BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
AND THEN WE HEARD A ITEM FIVE
ALREADY MEMBERS -- ASSEMBLY BILL%
ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY IS THERE A
MOTION ON THAT.
CENTER GALGIANI IS MOVE THE BILL
THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
CHIANG ARCHULETA.
PARTULA AYE DODD GALGIANI AT THE
AYE AYE HILL LABOR PAN.
PAN AYE WILK I REMEMBER THAT
BILL ON CALL AS WELL.
SO WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR THESE
TWO AUTHORS TO ARRIVE FOR THIS
FOR A FEW MORE MINUTES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
SO WE'LL TAKE A SHORT RECESS
.
OKAY -- I'M
OTHER PEOPLE REMEMBER YOU CAN
VERY FEW [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
CORD
COME.
FROM THE WOMAN CARILLO IS HERE
TO PRESENT ITEM THIRTEEN AB.
SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON HI MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS HELLO.
I'M HERE TO PROBABLY PERCENT OF
THEM THE BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO
WHICH SEEKS TO PROTECT PATIENT
ACCESS AND BETTER UTILIZE.
CALIFORNIA PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE
BY AMENDING FECHA.
STATUTORY LANGUAGE TO MORE
ACCURATELY REFLECT THE TRAINING
AND EXPERTISE OF OUR FAMILY
PHYSICIANS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I WILL WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
TO CONTINUE TO CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF FAMILY POSITIONS I
SUGGESTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
FAMILY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN
RECEIVE SPECIALIZED TRAINING AND
PREVENTIVE AND PRIMARY CARE FOR
PEOPLE FROM BIRTH. TO END OF
LIFE WHICH MAKES THEM UNIQUE IN
THE BREADTH OF KNOWLEDGE AND
ABILITY TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
CARE TO PATIENTS ACROSS ALL
SETTINGS.
UNFORTUNATELY A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF FAMILY MEDICINE
HAS RESULTED IN THE UNDER
UTILIZATION OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
LIMITING ACCESS TO CARE
RESTRICTING PATIENT CHOICE.
AND DISRUPTING CONTINUITY OF
CARE.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO WILL
REMEDY THIS PROBLEM BY SIMPLY
FIXING INCONSISTENCIES IN THE
LAW TO MORE ACCURATELY REFLECT
THE TRAINING AND EXPERTISE OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS.
AND TO IMPROVE PATIENT ACCESS
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS
DOCTOR EIGHTY A SCRUB WHO CAN
SPEAK OF THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BILL RATE WELCOME.
THE FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS IDEA SCRUBBING I AM A THIRD
YEAR FAMILY MEDICINE OF RESIDENT
PHYSICIAN AT JOHN MUIR FAMILY
MEDICINE RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
I HAVE BEEN EXTENSIVELY TRAINED
AND CHRONIC DISEASE MANAGEMENT
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OBSTETRICS
AND GYNECOLOGY PEDIATRICS
SURGICAL CARE GERIATRIC AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
WHEN I GRADUATE I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE FULL
SPECTRUM OF CARE TO THE FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS IN MY PRACTICE?
MANY REGULATORS DO NOT REALIZE
THAT FAMILY PHYSICIANS
SPECIALIZE IN PRIMARY CARE FOR
ALL AGES.
GENDERS IN ORGAN SYSTEMS.
IS ONE OF MY PATIENTS ONCE SAID
WE ARE THE SWISS ARMY KNIFE OF
HEALTH CARE.
WE MANAGE PREGNANCIES AND
DELIVER BABIES WE TREAT ASTHMA
DIABETES HYPERTENSION WE COUNSEL
DEPRESSED TEENS AND ADULTS WE
STITCHED TOGETHER CUTS WE REMOVE
SKIN LESIONS WE PROVIDE ANNUAL
SPORTS AND WELLNESS EXAMS WE
GUIDE PATIENTS TO THEIR FIRST
PUBLIC EXAMINE FAN THROUGH
MENOPAUSE.
WE ALSO DELIVER CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE AND COMPASSIONATE
AND OF LIFE CARE TO OUR SENIOR
CITIZENS IN CANCER PATIENTS.
THIS COMPLEXITY AND CONTINUE
CONTINUITY OF CARE IS WHAT%
INSPIRES OUR LOVE OF FAMILY
PRACTICE.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO IS THE
FIRST STEP IN TRYING TO DRESS
OUTDATED CODE SECTIONS. TO
BECOME BECOME MORE INCLUSIVE OF
THE POWER IN THE OF FICTIVE ROLE
FAMILY PHYSICIANS PLAY IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
BRENT MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR MOTION.
THE ACCOUNT CENTER PASS.
NO THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE SUMMER WOMAN
AQUIFER BRING THIS BILL FORWARD
IS A PEDIATRICIAN I CERTAINLY
AND AND FAMILIAR WITH THE WIDE
RANGE OF THESE -- AND THAT
FAMILY PHYSICIANS INVOLVED AND
AND AND THEIR TRAINING AS WELL
ACTUALLY.
FIND IT SORT OF IRONIC THAT --
YOU CAN BE A SPECIALIST.
SUPPOSEDLY TAKES SIX YEARS BUT
THE FOUND PHYSICIAN. THREE BUT
THAT'S JUST RESIDENTS YOU CAME
WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF EDUCATION
HAPPENS BEYOND THAT AS WELL --
SO CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BILL I
THINK THE AND I UNDERSTAND --
SOMEONE YOU'D SAID THAT YOU'RE
WILL WORK I THINK WE NEED TO BE
SURE WE LAND ON THE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE DEFINITION IN A WAY
THAT.
IS REFLECTIVE OF THE OF THE FOR
A FAMILY PHYSICIAN COMMUNITY
THAT WERE NOT EITHER X. BALL
IMPROPERLY EXCLUDING SOME PEOPLE.
OUT -- IN THE DEFINITION OR
MAKING IT OVERLY BROAD SO
CERTAINLY I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'LL BE WORKING THE COMMITTEE
ON THAT.
I HAVE A LITTLE EXPERTISE IN
THAT AREA THAT MIGHT BE A HELP
AS WELL AND I'M SURE OF COURSE
THE A. F. T. THAT YOU'RE
REPRESENTING A OBVIOUSLY HAS
SOME EXPERTISE THERE'S WELL SO.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
WORK THAT OUT THE REFINED THAT
NO WAY THAT'S GOING TO BE
APPROPRIATE BUT CERTAINLY WOULD --
SPEAKS FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD ANYONE SAYING CLOSING
ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
WELL ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
TWENTY TWO WITH AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT'LL
PROVIDE ACCESS ENABLE FAMILY.
PHYSICIANS WHO FULLY PRACTICUM
THE SPECTRUM A FAMILY.
OF MEDICINE WE KNOW THAT ACROSS
THE STATE THERE IS A LACK OF
NURSES THERE'S A LACK OF DOCTORS
WE ALWAYS DISCUSS.
PATIENT RATIOS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT FAMILIES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE A DOCTOR AND
GET THE HELP THAT THEY NEED AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
FELT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL TO US TODAY THANK YOU
DOCTOR SCRIPT FOR YOUR GREAT
EXPLANATION OF ALL THE WONDERFUL
THINGS THAT FAMILY PHYSICIANS DO --
IT'S QUITE A LIST AND I LOVE
YOUR SWISS ARMY KNIFE --
METAPHOR -- AND WITH THAT I
CENTER LATE I BELIEVE IS MOVE
THIS BILL.
AND WILL ASK THE SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D DONE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN.
AND I WILL.
WELCOME OKAY PLENTY VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OF PROGRESS IN
MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW I SEE IS HERE
AND WE HAVE A COLLECTION OF
WONDERFUL BILLS FROM THE CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY THE ANTI
COMMITTEE WELCOME.
AND WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN.
THEME GOOD MORNING MR.
LET'S SEE IF MAYBE IN ORDER
WHICH IS THE DENTAL BOARD IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU A. B..
FIFTEEN NINETEEN FIFTEEN
NINETEEN IT IS ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THIS IS THE
SUNSET BILL FOR THE TRANSPORT OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH WOULD EXTEND
THE OPERATION OF THAT SUPPORT.
BY ADDITIONAL FOUR YEARS WHILE
MAKING VARIOUS ADJUSTMENTS -- TO
THE DENTAL PRACTICE ACT IN
RESPONSE TO ISSUES RAISED DURING
OUR SENSE OF REVIEW PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
REBEKAH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I CAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION A CDA VALUES THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION TO THE
ISSUES RAISED IN THE SUNSET
REVIEW REPORT AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
CHANGES THE BILL MAKES TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES INCLUDING THE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE BOARD TO
APPOINT ITS OWN DEDICATED LEGAL
COUNSEL.
A IS ESSENTIAL FOR THE BOARD TO
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE TIMELY AND
ACCURATE LEGAL ADVICE ON ISSUES
AT BOARD MEETINGS AND DURING THE
NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES A NEW STREAMLINED
PROCESS BY WHICH A FOREIGN
DENTAL SCHOOL CAN OBTAIN
APPROVAL AND CALIFORNIA -- IN
ORDER TO RELIEVE THE BOARD OF
THIS RESPONSIBILITY CITY A WANTS%
TO ENSURE THAT THERE REMAINS A
FUNCTIONAL REVISED INTEREST WERE
THE APPROVAL PROCESS. FOR FOR
INTERNAL SCHOOLS AND IS
SYMPATHETIC TO THE BOARDS --
ARGUMENTS THAT IT DOESN'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES OR EXPERTISE TO
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE FOREIGN
DENTAL SCHOOLS.
CDA CONTINUES TO SUPPORT THE
CODA INTERNATIONAL ACCREDITATION
PROCESS AND CONSIDERS THAT AS AN
OPTION -- FOR FUTURE PATHWAY FOR
INTERNATIONAL DENTAL SCHOOL
APPROVAL I'M IN FINALLY CDA ALSO
SUPPORTS THE DENTAL BOARDS ON
GOING AND DEVOTED EFFORTS TO
COUNT TO COMBAT THE OPIOID
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION TO THE POLICY
STATEMENT APPROVED BY THE DENTAL
BOARD IN AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE BOARD HAS ALSO WORKED WITH
CDA. TO PROVIDE INFORMATION AND
RESOURCES TO LICENSEES INCLUDING
SHE FARIAN CTA'S ONLINE RESOURCE
GUIDE TO HELP DENNIS MEET
REQUIREMENTS -- AND FOLLOW BEST
PRACTICES ON PRESCRIBING OPIOIDS --
FOR THE TREATMENT OF PATIENTS
DENTAL PAID.
A CDA LOOKS FORWARD TO CONTINUED
WORK WITH THE DENTAL BOARD AS IT
BEGINS TO PROMULGATE REGULATIONS
ON A MANDATORY SEE COURSE AS
WELL THANK YOU.
VERY VERY GOOD NEXT WITNESS
RECUPERATE PRESENT IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF ORAL
AND MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS WE
ALSO SUPPORT MISTER LOW'S BILL
FIFTY NINETEEN WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE DENTAL BOARD.
AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED WITH
THEIR OPERATION AS THEY'RE
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT A YOUR BILL
MISTER CHAIRMAN SB FIVE OH ONE
SO WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB AB.
FIFTY NINETEEN VERY GOOD ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
PLEASE COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
THE NON BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
SOME WOMEN LET ME JUST THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK
THEY'VE DONE ON THIS -- THIS.
SUNSET REVIEW IT'S NOT EASY TO A
LOT OF ISSUES BUT I THINK IT'S
ALL BEEN HANDLED AN APPROPRIATE
WAY FOR **** YEAR GOOD WORK IN
THIS AREA.
SENATOR PAN IS MOVE THE BILL
ANYONE IS SAYING CLOSING.
GREAT THE SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I DON GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN AYE PAN AYE WILK
WILL DIE IT HAS A AN EFFORT TO
GET APPLE HOLD THE REAL OPEN
TRAPS IN MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM EIGHT A. B..
FIFTEEN TWENTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE CHAIR AT FOR SALT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMMITTEES WORK.
ALSO IN THIS.
BOARD SUNSET AND WILL ALSO BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS LISTED AND ANALYSIS A
TO EXTEND THESE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD BY ADDITIONAL FOUR YEARS
WHILE MAKING SEVERAL ADJUSTMENTS.
AT TO THE ISSUES RAISED IN THE
SENSE THAT REVIEW PROCESS
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE VERY
GOOD WITH THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TO BE
HEARD ON THE CHAIR OF THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD -- THANK YOU FOR
THE CONSIDERATION OF THIS IS MY
SECOND SUNSET REVIEW WE ARE VERY
MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO CARRY OUT.
OF THE LEGISLATIVE MANDATE TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS IN COURT
REPORTING.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNSSES IN
SUPPORT YES JIM GROSS AND
OPPOSITE THE DEPOSITION
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF. FOR
WORKING -- WITH US ON SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES REGARDING
OUT OF STATE CORPORATIONS.
AND WE WANT TO WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM ON A COUPLE
TECHNICAL ISSUES RELATING.
TO OUR FREELANCERS MAKING
CHARGES WHILE WORKING IN COURT
AND BETTER DEFINITION ON VOICE
WRITING TECHNOLOGY WITH THAT
THANK YOU FOR NOW FOR YOUR
SUPPORT VERY GOOD ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SO YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION SHARKS.
THE MORNING AFTERNOON WHATEVER
IT IS NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
HAVE A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED A
POSITION REALLY ON A COUPLE OF
ISSUES ONE IS THE VOICE -- LET
ME JUST START WITH THE OUT OF
STATE -- FIRM DEPOSITION FIRMS --
THE LANGUAGE THAT'S IN THE BILL --
WE THINK NEEDS TO BE FIXED HAVE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH COMMITTEE
BOTH COMMITTEES.
I'M ON THIS AT SOME THAT WE'VE
WORKED ON FOR A WHILE -- OUR
BIGGEST CONCERN IS THAT.
THE CORPORATION THE OUT OF STATE
FROM COURT IS NOT.
ON THE HOOK ENOUGH WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE CRB HAS FULL
AUTHORITY TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST
THE CORPORATION ITSELF.
AND ALSO THE FULL SPECTRUM OF
AUTHORITY THAT BOARD HAS NOW
COULD BE UTILIZED AGAINST.
THE FIRM THERE IS SOMETHING IN
THERE ABOUT A LICENSEE IN CHARGE
AND WE GET THAT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE FIRM
ITSELF -- WOULD BE ON THE HOOK
IN THE SAME WAY THAT TEXAS WHICH
IS THE HOME TO ONE OF THESE OUT
OF STATE FIRMS.
HAS.
AN EQUAL ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IMPROVED --
WITH THE BILL -- ON THE VOICE
WRITER.
DON'T OF YOUR **** WEBSITE
MISTER CHART OUT GO AHEAD OKAY
ON THE VOICE WRITER ISSUE --
I'LL SPEAK UP BOTH ON BEHALF OF
C. SORRY AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
S. YEAH YOU WE DO APPRECIATE THE
REFERENCE TO SOME OF THE SOME
LANGUAGE ON VOICE WRITERS --
BOTH SEIU AND C. C. R. A. I
THINK THAT THAT LANGUAGE NEEDS
TO BE IMPROVED -- WE HAVE
OUTLINED WAYS TO IMPROVE THAT
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THE BOARD.
HAS ON A SUFFICIENT AUTHORITY
BUT ALSO TO MAKE CLEAR -- THAT
VOICE WRITERS HAVE TO GO THROUGH
A CERTAIN PROCESS MORE SPECIFIC
PROCESS TO GET LICENSED IN THAT
THE BOARD CAN MANAGE THAT --
WE'VE HAD THESE DISCUSSIONS I
THINK IT'S GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION -- BUT IT'S NOT QUITE
THERE YET BUT HAPPY TO CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS GOING
FORWARD TO GET IT RIGHT -- AND
OTHER THAN THAT WE DO SUPPORT
THE BOARD ARE GOING FORWARD --
IF WE CAN GET THOSE THINGS FIXED
BUT WE REALLY DO THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT SPECIAL NOW STATE FIRM --
ONE WE THINK THERE'S JUST TOO
MANY GAPS THAT -- ULTIMATELY
WERE YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA WILL
REGRET TAKING THAT APPROACH.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE SHALL CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
WANT TO ECHO THE CONCERNS --
RACE BY MISTER HERNANDEZ AND
HOPE TO CONTINUE WORKING ON TO
MINUTES AND SPELL OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ANY ALEX ASKING FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
WANT ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED A MOMENT AGO.
OF DAY CONSIST OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT HAD IT WITH
YOU - PRIOR TO THIS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS -- SOME PARITY
WITH RESPECT TO SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY ANOTHER WILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS A
MOVING FOR BUT AT THIS TIME AS
PRESENTED -- TO WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS THE BEST A BILL THAT WE
HAVE A TO EXTEND THE BOARD AT
THIS TIME.
A SIMILE AS REFLECTED IN YOUR
AND ALICE'S SAID THERE'S BEEN NO
REGISTER OPPOSITION AS OF JULY
THIRD BUT I KNOW THAT WE ARE
ALWAYS OPEN TO DIGITAL
CONVERSATIONS BEFORE.
A GOOD ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YEAH -- SO CENTER ACTUAL AS
MOVING THE BILL AS AMENDED THE
AUTHOR EXCEPT TO THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE ANALYSIS.
WITH THAT THE US SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA ÁI DIçN GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN HI CAN I WILK
WE'LL GUIDE SAYS TWENTY OF US TO
GET OUT WILL GIVE THE ROLE OF
THE TRAPS IN MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP FIVE NINE
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AGAIN THANK YOU.
AGAIN -- FOR THE PARTNERSHIP
YOURSELF PARTNERSHIP ON LOOKING
AT A HOLISTIC APPROACH THIS --
ALSO INCORPORATING A FULL
COMMITTEES -- APPROACH TO A MANY
THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT
MIGHT HAVE EXISTED AND SO A WE
ARE.
DELIGHTED TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS REFLECT ON PAGES FOUR
FIVE NOW CSUS WHICH A CODIFIES
THE FEES.
ACCORDINGLY THIS BILL BEFORE US
IS THE CENTS A DAY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY
FOR UP TO FOUR YEARS.
AND AS NOTED IN THERE SUNSET
PAPER -- THIS HELPS N THE NON
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES HERE TO TEST
FIRE DISTURBANCES IN SUPPORT.
RESPECT GAS PRIVATE COULD HAVE
YOUR FIRST WITNESS -- WELL THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF AND FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS GEORGE
FAMILY ADD THEM UP PRESIDENT OF
THIS -- CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY -- WITH ME TODAY IS
A PETTY BOWERS THE CBA'S
EXECUTIVE OFFICER -- THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY
OR CPC P. A. IS THE STATE
AUTHORITY THAT LICENSE AND
REGULATE CERTIFIED PUBLIC
ACCOUNTANTS AND ACCOUNTING FIRMS
THAT OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE PROTECTION OF THE CONSUMERS
OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE
AND WISH TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW ALONG
WITH -- YOUR PERSPECTIVE STAFF
FOR YOUR SUPPORT DURING THE
SUNSET REVIEW THIS YEAR.
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT
DESCRIBED IN A COMEDIAN ALICE'S
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH IN STATUTE
THAT ITS INITIAL LICENSURE AND
RENEWAL FEE SHALL BE NO LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
AND NO MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DOLLARS.
SETTING THE MINIMUM AMOUNT OF
THOSE FEES AT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
WILL MAKE SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THE CBA'S
CURRENT NEGATIVE CASH FLOW.
HOWEVER WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE
ADDITIONAL FEE INCREASES BEYOND
THOSE AMOUNTS WILL BE NECESSARY
TO SUSTAIN THE CBA'S OPERATIONS
AND ESTABLISH AN ADEQUATE
RESERVE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON THESE
MATTERS.
AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MISSPELLED WORDS AND I ARE HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS -- YOU
OR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY
HAVE THANK YOU.
YEAH GOOD VERY GOOD I'M I'M TO
STEP OUT FOR JUST A MOMENT AND
CENTER WHAT'S GONNA CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MY ABSENCE GIVE ME.
OTHERS OTHERS SPEAKERS ARE THE
SCREEN NOW.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JASON FOX OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF CERTIFIED PUBLIC
ACCOUNTANTS TRUCKS FORCE WITH
LIKE THE AUTHOR AND A COMMITTEE
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE UP
THE GREAT WORK AND CAL
MORTARBOARD KELSEY STUFF
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED.
SEEING NO OTHER FOR FURTHER
COMMENTS THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS.
AS AMENDED [inaudible]
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THAT CALL
THE ROLL.
WHERE ARE YOU I GUESS WE'LL A
CLOSE?
HE IS ONE SMART ASSEMBLY MEMBER
[inaudible]
OKAY GLAZER [inaudible]
THANK.
RIGHT TO LEFT.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL.
LEYVA LIVE AYE PAN HI CAN I WILK
HI WILL GUIDE.
WE YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU HAVE
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET IT OUT BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON IN WITH THAT.
REMOVING THE ITEM NUMBER.
TEN AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS
DUE PASSED THE SENATE APPROACH.
AND WHENEVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE.
PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MEMBERS
THIS IS THE BILL TO EXTEND OUR
BOARD OF PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS
LAND SURVEYORS AND SHALL JUST
FOR ADDITIONAL FOR YEARS
ACCORDINGLY -- HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT.
IS THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
BOARD RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
NINE NANCY I SAY THE ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE POOR.
BORDERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF
BOTH COMMITTEES AND THEIR STAFF.
IN RECOGNIZING THE EFFORTS THE
FORD IS MAKING TO CONTINUE WITH
EFFICIENT OPERATION WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT ANYBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT YES G. V. AIRS ON BEHALF
OF THE SUCH AS ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ENGINEERING GEOLOGISTS -- WERE
IN SUPPORT AND ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE RICHARD
MARKETS AND AND WHO IS
REPRESENTS THE AMERICAN SOCIETY
OF CIVIL ENGINEERS REGION NINE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- TYLER MUNCHING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF INJURING COMPANIES AS WELL AS
THE STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANSTEY BAKER WITH THEIR IN
REDUCES HIS FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER BAKER.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING THEM PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS MOTIONS BEEN MADE BY
CENTER LEYVA.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENTS --
MISTER SOME WOMEN MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EXCELLENT STRONG CLOSE AND WITH
THAT.
DISCOVER THE VOTE.
QUESTION IS THE PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
GLAZER CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA ÁI DIFÑN GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN AYE PAN AYE WILK HI
OKAY.
AND THEN MEASURE PASSES -- WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND SO
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB.
FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE THAT HAS A
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS TO
SENATOR PROBES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN MEMBERS
THIS IS THE FINAL OF THE SENSE
OF BILLS FOR THE STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION THAT EXTENDED BY
ADDITIONAL FOUR YEARS AS NOTED
BY OUR SENSE AT BACKGROUND PAPER --
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTING CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE MEMBER AT
OTHER PEOPLE.
SPEAKING SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S ANDY FOSTER ON THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE STATE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION THE
COMMISSION'S IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY.
IN OPPOSITION.
THING THAT I MOVED BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS SENATOR ARCHULETA.
I'LL RECOGNIZE CENTER ARCHULETA
FOR MOVING THE BILL.
MR SO MEMORY MAY CLOSE
[inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT [inaudible]
EXCELLENT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARE TO LET AYE DODD GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE HILL.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE PAN.
PAN AYE WILK HI WILL GUIDE.
CONGRATS THE BILL'S APPLE
RELIEVE IT OPEN TO ALLOW OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON NO.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM TWELVE AB.
FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO DO PASSED TO
THE SENATE FOOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS AND
AND COMMITTEE -- THIS IS AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE WITH RESPECT
TO THE CANVAS VAPE COVERAGE IN
THE UNIVERSAL SYMBOL.
TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
INDUSTRY THAT CAN FOCUS ON THE
COMPLIANCE -- GIVEN THE RAGS AND
SO RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
IT WAS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER JENKINS THANK YOU FOR
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ANY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
AND COUNTY RAFT IN STRONG
SUPPORT ALSO PROUD CO SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL I'M THIS PROVIDES A
SENSIBLE SOLUTION TO THE SIZE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE UNIVERSAL
SYMBOL.
IT WILL ALLOW OPERATORS TO
AUTOMATE THE PROCESS -- ALSO
REDUCING COSTS AND MINIMIZING
MARKET DISRUPTION AND LSTLY
WILL ACTUALLY IMPROVE CONSUMER
KNOWLEDGE -- BY ALLOWING
OPERATORS TO PLACE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON TAPE CARTRIDGES
INCLUDING RATIO ALSO ALLOWING
THEM TO EXAMINE THE OIL THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR
INDUSTRY IS AFFECTING THE
INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW AND WE ARE A
TRIBE OF TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELANIE GRIFFITH
WITH CAN TANA WHAT'S IN HER MAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CMA THE
CALIFORNIA CANVAS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO A CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING
ON THIS MUCH NEEDED SOLUTION.
BOUNCES PUBLIC SAFETY WITH THE
PRACTICALITY OF PRINTING ON TAPE
CARTRIDGE.
GREAT THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON THE HUNGER SO LEASE ON
BEHALF OF UNITED CANNABIS
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TIM LYNCH ON BEHALF OF PACKS
LABSRAWESOME SUPPORT WILL MAKE
YOU.
ALICIA CREATE -- HAVEN'T EASE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
UNDER SENATORS ON BEHALF OF CARE --
IN MOXIE PRODUCTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU KAREN ORBIT ON BEHALF
OF THE CAMPUS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
AND HELGA SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF
PERFECT UNION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ENTRIES THE STEVENS ON BEHALF OF
NOR CAL CANNABIS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT WITH PRECISION
ADVOCACY GROUP ON BEHALF OF
BLOOM FARM SECURE BONTA NEW
TROPIC COMPANIES AS WELL AS TO
PROTECT COURT [inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
MEXICO WAS ABOUT A FULL CAR IN
SUPPORT -- MURPHY ON BEHALF WITH
MAPS AND SUPPORT.
GET THAT THANK YOU SENATOR
WELCOME ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OUR BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT ARE GALGIANI.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD THERE WERE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT.
ON THE BALLOT MEASURE ATTEMPTED
TO ADDRESS AT THE TIME AND WE
DON'T ALWAYS GET THINGS RIGHT
THE FIRST TIME IN SO THANK YOU
FOR BEING -- VIGILANT AND
RESPONSIVE TO THE INDUSTRY AND
FOR ADDRESSING THIS MATTER THAN
TO SIMPLIFY AND AND MAKE YOU
KNOW FORM AND STREAMLINED AND
AND WORK FOR THE INDUSTRY SO.
I WILL MOVE THE BILL.
RATE IN THEIR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS DATA CENTER GALGIANI
IS MOVING THIS BILL ANYTHING
WANNA SING CLOSING.
AGAIN SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE DODD
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN ALL RIGHT HAND I
WILL.
WILL TRY.
PLENTY OF US TO MOVE IT FORWARD
WITH THIS WHOLE CARRILLO PREFER
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT SO FOR THOSE WHO ARE
STILL HERE WE WILL GO BACK
THROUGH THE THE ITEMS IN CASE
YOU HAVE MISSED [inaudible]
ONE I ALL SET TO GO.
I KNOW THAT I SENATOR DODD AND
SENATOR HILL ARE AND THIS
UTILITY.
HEARING SO WE CAN ASK THEM IF
WHAT WHAT MIGHT BE CONVENIENT
FOR THEM TO COME DOWN TO VOTE
THAT WOULD BE GREAT BUT LET'S
BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE SR
FORTY EIGHT BY HUESO SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
HANG [inaudible]
DODD.
WHAT THE HELL?
LEYVA FIVE LEYVA AYE
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
WILL MOVE ON ITEM TO AB.
TWO FORTY ONE SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL -- MISSIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTES FOR DOES.
ZERO CHIANG.
DODD HILL LEYVA LEYVA AYE WILK.
WILL DIE.
I WILL MOVE ON ITEM THREE EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN BY GABRIELLA.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
WHICH IS TO PASS AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERR
BUT IT'S FIVE TWO ZERO CHIANG.
DODD HILL LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE.
MOVE ON TO ITEM FOR A V. EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
LIVING.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERN
VOTES [inaudible]
FOR TWO ZERO CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HILL.
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK.
WILL DIE MOVE ON ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR KERR VOTES.
FOR TWO ZERO CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HILL.
LEYVA RIGHT LEYVA AYE WILK.
BOOK I ARRIVE FOR THE CONSENT
NEXT CONSENT COUNT A. B. FIFTEEN
FOURTEEN BY PATTERSON.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
CHIANG DODD.
HILL LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE.
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN AB FIFTEEN NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
[inaudible]
SIX TWO ZERO CHIANG.
THIS IS A THE DENTAL BOARD
SUNSET ITEM.
SEVEN CHIANG I THOUGHT.
DODD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE.
AND IS THERE A BILLS AT NINE
ZERO NEXT ITEM ON A NUMBER EIGHT
TO AB FIFTEEN TWENTY BY LOW.
COURT REPORTERS SUNSET.
QUESTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
ITS AND APPROPRIATIONS CORRECT
VOTE SIX TWO ZERO CHIANG.
I CHIANG I'D DOT.
DODD AYE HILL HILL AYE.
RIGHT THAT'S OUT. TO EIGHT ZERO
NINETY NINE ZERO NEXT ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB.
FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTES FIVE TWO ZERO
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHANGE.
CHIANG I'D DODD DODD AYE HILL.
HILL I HAD BILLS OUT NINE ZERO
NEXT ITEM AT NINE TEN A. B.
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO BY LOW.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CRIME
VOTES FIVE TWO ZERO GLAZER HI
GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HILL HILL AYE AYE BILLS
AT NINE ZERO ITEM ELEVEN A. B.
FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE BY LOW.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTES FIVE TWO ZERO GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HILL PHIL I HAD BILLS
AT NINE ZERO ITEM TWELVE A. B.
FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE BELLA.
MOTION AS THE PASSED THE SENATE
FLOOR KERR ABOUT SIX TWO ZERO
CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D DODD DODD AYE HILL
HILL AYE.
AT BILLS AT NINE ZERO NEXT ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY TWO BY CARILLO.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERN
VOTE SIX TWO ZERO CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D DODD DODD AYE HILL
HILL AYE THOSE AT NINE ZERO NEXT
UP ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN NINETY SIX BY CHAO.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERN
VOTES.
FOR TWO ZERO TANK CHIANG AYE
DODD AYE DODD AYE HILL HILL AYE
LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL.
OKAY.
I REGISTERED AT THE TOP THIS IS
ITEM.
AT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
STARTED THE TOP FILE ITEM ONE SR
FORTY EIGHT BY HUESO.
THANK THANK YOU [inaudible]
CHIANG I DODD.
DODD AYE HILL HILL AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
NINE ZERO ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO
FORTY ONE BY COM LOCKER DOVE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
CHANGE NINE CHIANG I'D DODD DODD
AYE HILL PHIL I BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
GABRIEL.
CHIANG BY CHIANG I'D DODD.
DODD AYE HILL HILL AYE BILLS AT
NINE ZERO ITEM FOR A. B. EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT BY LEVINE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
CHANG.
CHANG I DOT.
DOT I HILL HILL AYE.
AND BILLS OUT NINE ZERO ITEM
FIVE AB ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE BY
COOLEY SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
CHIANG NO.
CHIANG NOW.
DOT.
DOT I HILL.
HILL AYE.
HE HAD BILLS AT EIGHT TO ONE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR A. B. FIFTEEN
FOURTEEN BY PATTERSON.
CHIANG CHIANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HILL HILL AYE THAT
FILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO BELIEVE THAT COMPLETES
OUR WORK OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
AM I MISSING ANYTHING I GOT IT
COVERED.
THANKS STAFF AGAIN FOR ALL THEIR
GOOD WORK AND THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING LISTENING WITH THAT OUR
MEETING SUBJECT